E aí
[Música]
É
assim nós complementamos lá na Síria
marca avó e uma palavra ar marca
composta por 2 partes primeiro mar que
significa Deus que raiva significa amor
então marcava para você ver
Olá meu nome é Luciana russa eu sou da
Síria e hoje vim contar uma história de
longe para vocês
eu como a maioria das pessoas tinham uma
vida normal e tranquila
e chega de lembranças boas e ruins
subidas e descidas igual todo mundo
mas em 2011 começou a guerra e a minha é
a minha vida mudou totalmente e a vida
de todos os filhos para quem não conhece
a Síria
antigamente e muitos anos atrás essa
região se chama a grande Síria ela
reuniu muitos povos muitas civilizações
E durante as épocas e as guerras que é
que aconteceu lá essa área foi dividida
por países que a gente conhece hoje como
Síria Líbano Jordânia aqui embaixo
por isso nós não somos são árabes não
somos uma soma de todos os povos que
moravam lá de todas as civilizações que
moravam lá no somos um pouco de casa
ó e aqui são alguns exemplos das
civilizações são moravam
igual a Mari na área de agricultura e
blá nas joias ogarett na música O Povo
sumério assírios fenícios e assim vai
não somos uma soma de todas essas
pessoas que moravam lá nós somos um povo
cheio de história rica
Oi e eu só de Aleppo a segunda maior
cidade da Síria a cidade mais antiga e
tem muita história para contar uma
história
o que tem muitos detalhes a gente anda
na cidade veja veja cada pedra
e aguardando uma história muito antiga
em qualquer pessoa que queria fazer
arquitetura
eu sempre cair na prova 1 questão de
desenho um desenho de fachada um desenho
de uma mesquita de uma igreja de um
prédio de um mercado por porque isso faz
parte da nossa história
e por isso eu acabei escolhendo a
arquitetura porque eu gosto de ouvir
histórias gosto de fazer parte de um
prédio de uma construção
em 2011 a minha vida mudou totalmente
como sou a guerra e todo mundo achava
que acabar um dia a gente não acreditava
que ia chegar na nossa casa que ia
chegar mais perto mas infelizmente não
foi assim a cidade foi destruída
Perdemos muitas coisas muitas histórias
muitas muitos prédios muitos lugares
turísticos que hoje em dia não existe
mais nos perdemos muito mas não é tudo
em 2013
o outro ano que foi bem marcante na
minha vida quando o homem na faculdade e
foi bombardeada
e quando acabou tudo acabou o meu futuro
perdi meus alguns amigos perdi a minha
vida perdi meu sonho que eu queria
realizar não conseguia fazer nada o
mundo acabou a cidade estava fechada
ninguém pode sair ninguém podia entrar
faltava água comida dos tudo que que a
gente precisa para viver tudo isso
faltou e não tinha mais esperança
e Essa foi a última foto que a gente
conseguiu tirar eu e meus amigos Cada um
foi para um lugar cada um buscou uma
vida nova uma coisinha dá uma
oportunidade melhor uma vida mais segura
e hoje em dia a gente se comunica nas
redes sociais
e quando acabou o meu futuro 2013 eu
fiquei pensando o que que eu vou fazer
agora mas sorte meu
e é conheci meu marido e nós decidimos
construir a nossa família mas embaixo
das Bombas Com certeza não dá por isso
nós decidimos fugir para outra cidade
casar para buscar uma nova vida
a Camus e deu tudo certo tranquilo e
agora aonde vamos
eu voltar para ler para o perigoso
continuar numa país que está sendo
destruída na tua frente também perigoso
Como são os abrir o mapa e pensamos e
agora onde vai ser o nosso destino Para
onde vamos
2013 foi bem difícil os países abrir as
portas para os refugiados porque todo
mundo queria fugir todo mundo queria um
lugar mais seguro
o e sorte nosso nós descobrimos que o
Brasil estava abrindo as portas
Nós pedimos um visto de turista lá no
Líbano e viemos para cá Chegamos aqui
pedimos o refúgio nós somos estamos
refugiados agora
Já começou o novo capítulo da nossa vida
novo capítulo cheio de desafios de lutas
dificuldades
estudo uma criança perdida na rua você
não sabe para onde ir como começar a
língua nova trabalho novo não sabemos
como fazer como começar esse apoio do
início da vida é bem bem importante para
qualquer pessoa estrangeira inclusive
também que isso já
e para quem não fala a língua
ele precisa trabalhar
ninguém contrata uma pessoa que não fala
português e agora como fazemos
nós começamos
trabalhar na culinária árabe
começamos vender comida para os vizinhos
amigos participar de feiras eventos
fazer bazares para gente sem pegar um
pouquinho mais rápido com uma essa nova
vida sem integrar e fazer amigos
é mas durante todo esse tempo o sonho de
estudar e continuar estudando nunca
sumiu na minha cabeça queria muito
estudar eu parei no terceiro ano eu
queria
continuar minha curso de arquitetura
e todo mundo naquela época falava para
mim é impossível é um sono você não fala
a língua precisa de muito tempo para
conseguir uma vaga na universidade
Oi e eu quase desisti desisti de tudo
porque eu achava que ele que eu não ia
conseguir
mas em 2014 Eu e meu marido estávamos
andando na cidade e Vimos a placa
Universidade Federal do Paraná
e entramos e o sorte nosso que não
professor que o coordenador do curso
Professor Paulo kieza expliquei toda a
minha vida para ele veio todos os
documentos que ele conseguir trazer da
Síria expliquei tudo e ele ficou
interessado da minha história e abrir o
computador como se fosse escrever
escrever escrever assim não falou para
mim assim aqui e eu fiquei olhando vou
assinar um documento que não sei o que
que tá escrito dentro dele
mas falei não eu vou assinar o que que
vai acontecer vai acontecer depois de
uma semana me ligou o salão parabéns
você tá atrasada na federal O Milagre
começou a 2014
é o desafio foi aumentando cada dia o
desafio de chegar até o fim
e eu queria só agradecer todas as
pessoas que ficavam comigo que vai
apoiar a minha família meu esposo
meus amigos que traduziram todas as
aulas para mim em inglês para eu
conseguir acompanhar eles todos os
amigos que fique acreditar em mim para
ir que eu vou conseguir realizar meu
sonho que eu vou conseguir chegar o
momento
o computador duro bom e falar em 2017 eu
sou arquiteta e urbanista
finalmente depois de três anos de
Sofrimento de estudo de noites sem
dormir eu consegui eu consegui para
mostrar para todo mundo que os
refugiados podem realizar os sonhos
deles fora do país que nada difícil e
nada é impossível
E aí
e
para trazer uma tema que tem muito a ver
com minha história eu fiz um centro de
acolhimento para os refugiados em
Curitiba um centro que acolhe todos os
refugiados estão o primeiro apoio na
documentação na moradia em tudo
E eu chamei ele de Júri o júri é um tipo
de flor muito famoso lá na Síria a gente
sempre acostumada a plantar elas nas
nossas casas
esse centro recebeu também arquitetura
assíria o pátio interno algumas
elementos nas fachadas eu queria trazer
muito a minha alma nesse centro
a
e trazer arquitetura EA culinária não
sou suficiente para mim Nós também
trouxemos a nossa alma Síria a nossa
banda viu a uma Síria meu marido abre
toca alaúde minha cunhada a Miria tocar
Antônio e eu tanto no sempre acreditamos
que a nossa história é bem rica e a
nossa responsabilidade e sempre é
transmitir ela é o mundo inteiro levar
as ondas músicas da árvores antigas
tradicionais para que todo mundo conhece
a nossa realidade todo mundo conhece a
história da Síria
eu ia sempre falo que nada difícil nessa
vida nós temos que acreditar no nosso
poder interno a nossa potência que onde
nós estejamos nessa terra nós podemos
mudar o mundo nós podemos vencer e
realizar nossos sonhos
hoje e sempre
para mudar o seu futuro basta lutar por
aquele que você gosta por aquele que
você ama né